Parato sama sambodasa Parato sama sambodasa Parato sama sambodasa
Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hato samasambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hato samasambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hato samasambuddhassa
Can you take the picture of this?
Satsang with Mooji
bhagavato arhato sambha sambhutasa namo tassa bhagavato arhato sambha sambhutasa namo tassa bhagavato arhato sambha sambhutasa
As long as I can... No, no, no, no, no.
As long as I've got a stick on my neck.
Just that one little bit.
No, but this discourse has got lots more words.
Yes.
It's a bit tricky.
Oh, you've got one.
It's not that tricky.
Which lady?
Oh, this lady.
I won't.
Thank you.
No one's in there, thank you.
.
Do you want this one too?
Satsang with Mooji
.
Namo tassa-bhagavad-bhagavad-bhagavad
We need a fan.
These are the wreckages and precepts, so we repeat after Bhante.
Sādhu, sādhu, sādhu, sādhu.
Namo tassa bhagavato arhato sama sambuddhassa.
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sama sambudassa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sama sambudassa
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sama sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sama sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato
Satsang with Mooji
.
tujhiyam pe dhamam saranam gacchami tujhiyam pe sadham saranam gacchami
kathiyampi-sangham sarnam gacchami kathiyampi-budham sarnam gacchami kathiyampi-nuram sarnam gacchami kathiyampi-dhamam sarnam gacchami
.
Whoever's going to read the first discourse.
Fine.
Thus have I heard.
On one occasion the Blessed One was dwelling at Baranasi in the deer park at Isipatana.
There the Blessed One addressed the monks of the group of five thus,
Monks, these two extremes should not be followed by one who has gone forth into homelessness.
What two?
The pursuit of sensual happiness in sensual pleasures, which is low, vulgar, the way of worldlings, ignoble, unbeneficial, and the pursuit of self-mortification, which is painful, ignoble, unbeneficial.
Without veering toward either of these extremes, the Tathagata has awakened to the middle way, which gives rise to vision, which gives rise to knowledge, and leads to peace, to direct knowledge, to enlightenment, to nibbana.
And what, monks, is that middle way awakened to by the Tathagata?
It is this noble eightfold path that is right view, right intention, right speech, right action, right livelihood, right effort,
right mindfulness, right concentration.
This, monks, is that middle way awakened to by the Tathagata, which gives rise to vision, which gives rise to knowledge, and leads to peace, to direct knowledge, to enlightenment, to nibbana.
Now this, monks, is the noble truth of suffering,
Birth is suffering, aging is suffering, illness is suffering, death is suffering, union with what is displeasing is suffering, separation from what is pleasing is suffering, not to get what one wants is suffering.
In brief, the five aggregates subject to clinging are suffering.
Now this monks is the noble truth of the origin of suffering.
It is this craving that leads to renewed existence, accompanied by delight and lust, seeking delight here and there.
That is craving for sensual pleasures, craving for existence, craving for extermination.
Now this monks is the noble truth of the cessation of suffering.
It is the remainderless fading away and cessation of that same craving, the giving up and relinquishing of it, freedom from it, non-attachment.
Now this, monks, is the noble truth of the way leading to the cessation of suffering.
It is this noble eightfold path that is right view,
Right view, right intention, right speech, right action, right livelihood, right effort, right mindfulness.
Right concentration.
Sadhu.
So now we will make our way and we'll give it a chance.
Sabae sata sukhita hantu.
Sabbe satta sukita hondur Sabbe satta sukita hondur
Sabhe satta sukita hantu Sabhe satta sukita hantu
sāve sāta-sukhi-taṁ tu sāve sāta-sukhi-taṁ tu
SAVE SATA SUGITA HONDU SAVE SATA SUGITA HONDU
Sabe sata sukita hantu Sabe sata sukita hantu
Satsang with Mooji Satsang with Mooji
So now we'll chant the Metta Sutta and then there'll be a reading of it.
CHOIR SINGS
.
Dawa Sambhawesiwa Sabhe Satta Bhavantu Sukhita Tha Namparo Paranmikubhe Tena Dimanyi Dekat Tertinangkanchi Nyaro Sanapatikasanya Nanyamanyasadukyamicheya Matayataniyanko
Satsang with Mooji Satsang with Mooji Satsang with Mooji
Satsang with Mooji Satsang with Mooji
.
the Metta Sutta.
If you are wise and want to reach the state of peace, you should behave like this.
You should be upright, responsible, gentle and humble.
You should be easily contented and need only a few things.
You should not always be busy.
You should have the right sort of work.
Your senses should be controlled and you should be modest.
You should not be exclusively attached to only a few people.
You should not do the slightest thing that a wise person could blame you for.
You should always be thinking, may all beings be happy.
Whatever living beings there are, be they weak or strong, big or small, large or slender, living nearby or far away, those who have already been born and those who have yet to be born.
May all beings without exception be happy.
You should not tell lies to each other.
Do not think that anyone anywhere is of no value.
Do not wish harm to anyone, not even when you are angry.
Just as a mother would protect her only child at the risk of her own life, so you should let the warmth of your heart go out to all beings.
Let your thoughts of love go through the whole world with no ill will and no hate.
Whether you are standing, walking, sitting or lying down, so long as you are awake, you should develop this mindfulness.
This, they say, is the noblest way to live.
And if you do not fall into bad ways, but live well and develop insight,
and are no longer attached to all the desires of the senses, then truly you will never need to be reborn in this world again.
So we can make our way to the Marquis.
Thank you.